the Joe Rogan experience you ever seen a
Wolverine chase off wolves Oh Wolverines
are a little it's like a 35 pound animal
everything gets the [ __ ] away from it
because they're so ferocious they're so
crazy and they feel like no pain yeah
like things could bite them and like
their will chase wolves they'll chase
bears what's the news with Connor by the
way is he throwing out that he wants to
fight someone he wants to fight kabhi
kabhi but he's they're trying to set up
look we are well if this in the future
this is March 24th on Tuesday and
everyone's on [ __ ] full lockdown here
they're talking about doing a UFC they
don't know where it's gonna be for
khabib versus Tony Ferguson they're
talking about doing that somewhere
somewhere in another country you know I
told Danish do it on a battleship just
doing a battleship in international
waters fly everybody in the helicopter
[ __ ] cool idea and there's no
organization like the UFC that could
pull that off yeah you can't do that
with like any other sport no because you
don't need many very many people you
just need the fighters yeah I mean I
don't even know if they're gonna have an
undercard and the more like the crazier
the setting you're a fight the morgues
like they could be like and there'll be
Lions roaming and they would imagine one
of those sheiks that has you know a
trillion dollars does they do it in my
palace honey the palace you said octagon
in a giant ballroom dude if you guys
called sheiks and and like do you want
it like they would start a problem yeah
this is no problem at all this is come
on yeah they'll [ __ ] sanitize the
[ __ ] out a couple jets fly everybody in
sanitize the runway just crates of Lysol
absolutely crop duster plane spraying
lice all over everything it would be
they would do it right actually they
have so much money yeah I mean they they
could do it right they could test
everyone well what do you do if someone
has like is they're asymptomatic and
they want to fight anyway and but they
test positive yeah
you gotta go you gotta go what if it's
Tony Lee test positive but they're
asymptomatic too much of its resting
heart rates low everything's fine
too much of you Goldie you're shedding
it man shedding it as you walk around
after he's over we just cover him in a
big plastic suit I guess if the other
fighter was like I'm cool with it yeah
it's a beam to probably be cool with it
too
yeah sure yeah send location bring
medicine
[Applause]